so instead of just saying that i'm going
to work 12 hours a day
no i'm gonna work let's say six hours a
day
but those are highly concentrated hours
with large
breaks in between which resets your
energy to like 90 percent
[Music]
danny thank you so much for being on my
show 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm doing great thank you for having me
definitely
you know i we we edited this out but a
second ago i said thank you for having
me on 20-minute leaders
so i think you know this is actually the
75th episode or so that we're
recording so you would think that by
then i would know how to introduce
people
well i guess that's just not the case uh
danny
um really really interesting guy that
i'm really excited to get to know you
better
over these next 20 minutes or so you
worked
on an on a marketplace app called salee
with a good friend
of mine from the teal summit a forbes 30
under 30 now forbes tech council
talk to me a little bit about about
where you come from and how you even got
into this entrepreneurial world
cool yeah well i come from a
very far country in the middle east
called lebanon
and this story
actually started 10 years ago but we
have
time i think yeah yeah
uh so of course uh as a child i was just
obsessed with computers
even before the internet so we just um
got our first computer when i was seven
years old
but i was more interested in creating
rather than just consuming like playing
games it was fun but i wanted to build
something so uh the only tool i had back
then was
microsoft powerpoint and i just kind of
find a way
to build a simple games like just
multiple questions games on top of that
and this was my first encounter to
programming
um later on moving forward i just
went to a computer engineering program
but i quickly realized that they're not
teaching us
anything practical so all what we
learned
was theory and i wanted to like build
websites mobile
apps um the iphone just came out and
mobile apps were just
very very early stage and um
i remember i just couldn't afford to buy
a mac so i went and
worked as like a waiter at a barista
actually as
really at a coffee shop wow
so i i made enough money to buy the mac
and then the first thing i thought about
is
let me just build an app for them for
the coffee shop and then i just
sold it to them and quit and so very
cool
yeah i started pursuing my career as a
you went from a waiter to building an
app for the coffee shop and then you
and then quit as a waiter and you and
you okay and so
then how do you get to let's fast
forward a little bit
to staley how do you get to building
this really incredible marketplace where
at the end you you actually merged
with mercari right yeah uh so uh
for sale actually it was uh just
hackathons at the beginning
hackathons were still new concept i just
went there
i was just like i won the first
hackathon for some reason
and then met this guy uh uh
he was just 15 years old back then but
he was just very bright and we decided
to just
team up and uh started like hacking the
judging criteria and
making some prizes cash prizes and going
home
at some point one of the judges was like
hey you guys i see you all the time in
those hackathons
just waiting and doing nothing about it
are you gonna build something
and that we were like yeah let's do it
so we just bought a ticket
flew to san francisco and um
this is how all started it all started
and sadie was just
like the last idea that won at a
competition we decided to
it was just a marketplace to buy and
sell second-hand items but it was
sailing was actually a hackathon
it was a hackathon idea a startup
weekend idea yeah
oh very cool um and then um
it just started growing um things worked
out also somehow
the timing i think was very good because
mobile apps were just
on the rise and uh it was kind of like a
mobile ebay at that point and
lots and lots of competitors were
building those
um kind of apps at the same time and
raising hundreds millions of dollars
just to grow up to
something like offer up even before let
go
um even much way before facebook
marketplaces and all of those
so what year are we talking about so
salee was uh the marketplace to buy and
sell second-hand items
and uh the timing was good for it to
grow
and then after like six years of working
on it
we ended up with uh uh joining mercari
so when when did you start when did you
start working back in
in 2013 2013
yeah oh wow okay so okay that's really
an interesting time to start
building mobile apps and marketplaces
exactly exactly yeah okay we didn't know
back then but
of course of course yeah and so what was
that experience you know growing the app
from one user yourself to 500 000 users
yeah uh that was very exciting times for
us because
we learned as we as we were going um
we were just growing um
finding new ways to do user acquisitions
to um find our target market
who are the people who are gonna use it
uh to fight fraud and scammers
we scammed a lot at the beginning like
those fraudsters but
we learned as we you know you lose a lot
of money but
tom tell me about one of those scams
what were you scammed with
usually so so usually uh they get stolen
credit cards
and then they buy expensive items of our
platform
they finish the transaction and then at
the end of the month
stripe would be sending us like a a
dispute
and saying hey this credit card was
stolen
we're gonna take the money out of your
bank account
whoa okay yeah stripe didn't have fraud
detection back then
it was just very early so we had to
integrate with other services to
figure that out but by then we had we've
lost like
20 000 or something just because there
was a delay before we knew it was
happening
so you know but marketplaces really you
need you need both ends of the stick you
need both the sellers and the buyers
yeah right and you need them at scale in
order to really
you know building build a good
experience so how do you go about even
strategizing how to get
you know both the to get really the
sellers on this platform
exactly yeah what we did was uh we
started at
specific cities so in new york city for
example
and even targeting specific kind of
people um right san francisco the
techies
like you know uh each area with high
population has
um a a good amount of people's
that usually sell and buy specific items
and this is how we
initially started and then it just
expands as you go and grows
but the the initial part is the hardest
part to get
definitely no i'm sure okay so so then
you go and you
and you're building this amazing
platform how many people are you on the
team
we were a small team of like five people
we didn't want to
to hire uh people uh just for the sake
of
like showing that the the company is
expanding or growing
and we were we are um very good at fast
execution and and
um getting the best out of every single
person
so we were doing at least like the work
of five to ten
engineers for example in another company
a big company for example sure yeah it's
just the tools that we built like we
built abstract layer later on which
got us into uh for study under 30. that
was mainly because of sailing we were
like
oh look what is abstract layer okay so
so it's a
an automation platform um and we
realized that
we're building those components and
features for salee
and a lot of things are just very
similar if you look at it
from a high level so those are table
views that you scroll through or
grid views or like the data showing and
interacting with it is
very common across different apps across
different screens
so we just thought about an abstraction
to it where instead of writing down
or coding stuff you can just do it in
like let's say uh two lines of code you
can just do
what thousands lines of code could do
and then this
allowed us to to build um
product and features and and everything
else till today i still use it
with our new startup um
it allows us to go for uh an execution
from
like something that would take a month
would take three days
and this is huge for anyone who's
pursuing startups and trying to build
fast
so is that like a package or a product
exactly
it's a framework uh where you just drag
it into your
xcode project in our case which for ios
and then out of the box it has so much
things that you can do
to just build the same uh
data um the binding and and uh viewing
and interactions
in seconds right okay so then so you
build abstract layer and then that gets
you on the on the forbes 30 under 30
congratulations
and you're then under 32 right
yes yeah we can talk about you later
in another time thank you i can
interview you
sounds great and and then but but so
what is this
forbes tech council that you're that
you're part of
so uh first tech council is um they have
very strict um
uh requirements to get in uh whether
it's on your uh startup um
revenue or net worth or whatever
the criteria is and then once you get in
um
you start contributing to uh forbes
tech um so you're writing uh tech
articles you're doing consultancies and
uh there's also a
huge forum where everyone from the
industry are are asking
questions and everybody is giving their
experience right
right so it's a huge network actually
it's a small network of
like successful entrepreneurs and and
and
people in the tech industry sure that
can help each other and help others by
just
um sharing their knowledge outside no
that makes sense so what are you usually
right about what do you enjoy writing
about
so for me it's all about engineering
productivity for example
really i love that yeah yeah of course
um
so anything from building tools to help
you from the mentality how to schedule
your day what kind of
things to tackle um so i i care a lot
about
um having like just one engineer on my
team that can be
20x as other just like people who are
employed at
companies and are doing what they're
told to without sure thinking of how can
we make it faster how can we build
even better things definitely so
so okay so you know i'm an engineer by
profession as well
how do i increase my productivity and to
any other engineers that might be
interested in this
what what can i what should i be
thinking of when i prioritize and when i
schedule my work day
yep okay uh that's a very good question
there are
lots of different areas to tackle but
for example
um what worked for me is having
i work from home i've been working from
home for more than a year now
and i've done it even before so what
really works
is discipline having a specific
daily schedule for yourself and going
by very relevant in covet 19 times oh
yeah
yeah so for example for me i usually
wake up at
8 by myself without an alarm because i
i'm used to it um and then
i have my coffee and breakfast while
having a conversation
with my business partner to discuss the
business in general and what we're gonna
achieve in the next day in this day
um then work for till
lunch then to our break i i realized
that
taking a long break resets my energy
so instead of just saying that i'm going
to work 12 hours a day
no i'm gonna work let's say six hours a
day
but those are highly concentrated hours
with large
breaks in between which resets your
energy to like 90
instead of just trying to go through the
day with when justice left
and even i do that again like at let's
say 6 p.m
if if i still want to work more i can
just take a big
gap of two hours three hours and then go
again
three hours and those will be very high
productivity
slots okay now that that's just
fascinating
i can talk a lot more about it but i
think we don't have enough
well what i would love to also hear er i
don't get to meet
too many lebanese entrepreneurs and i'd
love to hear a little bit about
the lebanese tech scene and your
interpretation of it you know coming
from lebanon
having the silicon valley experience
being a successful entrepreneur
and how so talk to me a little bit about
what the
ecosystem is like and what do you see
your your role in it
awesome yeah um what i can say about uh
lebanese people is they're very
ambitious uh
they're um they the problem is they
usually
have to travel outside and then shine
outside
uh because of the very limited
opportunities
that we have in our country uh but again
the tech scene and the
startup scene is relatively big
compared to the middle east also in
lebanon
uh we do have vcs a lot of vcs and and
angels that help
uh this uh ecosystem um
but the market is also very tiny like
the lebanese
market is super tiny because we have a
population of like five million
uh credit card penetration is still low
uh so whenever you're building a
startup in lebanon you're at least
targeting the middle east
and not just lebanon and um
and usually uh people would just decide
to travel
abroad europe or or the us
just to be able to get even more and
then excel more
sure so the people in your community and
do they look up to you as sort of
someone who's you know done it
and who got out shined
became an extremely successful
entrepreneur something that you really
you know you read about in the news and
on techcrunch and all of a sudden you're
coming back and
do they ask you for advice or how do
they perceive you
yeah well it's not just me like we have
a lot of successful entrepreneurs and
and whenever we're
at home uh uh a lot of uh the uh
new startups and and people who are just
experiencing this for the first time or
even like couple times that didn't
do well they always look up to people
who have achieved something especially
if you went to silicon valley like
that's definitely a prank
but even from uh if you went to other
places and built something
they just ask for advice they try to see
if
what's a good way to travel themselves
outside to be able to be successful and
to do
more things outside no no no that makes
a lot of sense
and so do you often go back and forth do
you get together a lot
uh yeah yeah i usually go like three
times a year oh wow okay that's a lot
it's a long
flight yeah yeah oh yeah i'm from i'm
from israel so
it's pretty much the same amount of same
amount of hours for a flight 20-hour
flight
usually yeah i got used to it but but
yeah it's
worth it i think because you have family
there because you have
all your history food
yeah so lots of you have to look forward
to yeah 100
so danny what are you excited about now
there's so much ahead of you
where do you see yourself moving ahead
what gets you excited
yeah well uh at some point uh in the
past couple years i just realized that
this is my life i'm i'm always gonna be
that person
starting new companies or well actually
it's just
more of creating values and creating
value in the world which
for me is starting new businesses
and companies um and uh this is what i'm
doing also right now like right now
we're also uh since uh we we
quit with uh from mercari because at the
end of the day
you wanna work on something that you own
and and you love and um
so this is what i'm working on right now
and i'm going to be working on for a
very long time as well
of course of course and and any specific
industries that you're especially
curious about
and that you're that you're so um yeah
i'm usually open to
different industries especially if
there's something new i i
tried things in um in vr
for example uh last year um in uh
like whenever there's something special
crypto or whatever came up
i just want to explore is there anything
that can be built that can help actually
and and you and also make money at the
same time um
but i think my my strong suit is
e-commerce
and uh because i've been in it for 10
years
i know the ins and outs and also uh
i've been in in contact with a lot of
the bigger competitors as well
so sure kind of you want to be
in this principle in something in the
market that you know
more than any one other other person
probably in in the world
to be able to build some extra value
that nobody is seeing right now
of course of course danny 20 minutes is
almost up but i have to ask you
my last question which is also my
favorite question and can you tell me
three words that
you would best describe yourself as or
that maybe your co-founder would
describe you as
looks like a an interview question
definitely
what's your weakest point i'm gonna go
for the strongest points
yeah i work way too hard i try to make
too much money for the company
yeah i think uh it could be um
ambitious that's number one yeah um but
be
a persistent like always trying to to
follow things
through and i'm probably a geek also
i love it that's the most important one
i think
yeah i love it danny thank you so much
for the time
thank you so much for for for for
forming this new friendship and i'd love
to continue learning from you and it's
and and say say hi to your co-founder a
great great friend of mine
and and i wish you all the best on your
next ventures thank you so much for
having me
of course take care bye